I've been testing fitness bands with
built-in heart rate sensors for the last
month here are some things that actually
happen to me they just climb to 17
flights of stairs there's no way my
heart rates at 77 100 beats per minute
sounds a little high for channel surfing
that's why I'm here at my cardiologist
office yes some of the numbers I've seen
on these wrist-worn heart rate monitors
have made me pretty worried but I also
wanted to see just how accurate they are
so doctor oh sure is my heart okay it's
a young a normal healthy beautiful
marvelous looking heart so what you're
saying is my heart's okay yes it's very
okay and your heart rate is also kind of
slow it here it looks like it's about 60
which is a very good resting heart rate
the next step was a stress test and to
compare the EKG readings to the optical
heart rate sensors in the basis peak and
the Microsoft band I've been testing
when I was just standing still both
bands had comparable results to the
Machine right now I'm getting 86 on my
wrist here what is what's the Machine
saying baby 6 it seems to be locked at
71 72 and the Machine said exactly the
same but when I started moving things
didn't stick so well so you're saying
it's about a hundred yes well now it
could be 110 the basis is still at 90
but companies like polar and garments a
chest strap monitors are far more
accurate and that's exactly what I found
you're about 120 ish here okay 120 there
119 here excellent the polar stuck with
it too even when the workout got harder
when the EKG said I was at 130 the polar
said 132 basis said 115 and Microsoft
100 when the EKG was at 146 the polar
was exactly at 146 the basis caught up a
bit at 135 but Microsoft was still stuck
at 100 the Microsoft band was especially
badly behaved at the doctor it's
typically worked better in my testing
especially during workouts Microsoft and
bases say the sensors are sampling heart
rate many times a second and some of the
issues could be related to my wrist size
and the positioning of the band
still the doctor agreed that the chest
strap while more uncomfortable and
inconvenient will be more accurate well
I for one am feeling much better that my
heart is okay but what I'm not feeling
better about is the fact that many of
these $200 fitness bands like the
Microsoft and the basis are giving us
readings we just shouldn't take to heart
if you're looking to measure your heart
rate during workouts especially I would
go with a heart rate strap like this one
from polar or this one from Garmin or
find your local cardiologist they fit
you're in good shape and drive I do you
guys heard it here first right here
first